finally i want to emphasize again that a
key requirement in mobile web
development is optimizing for battery
usage battery life in your user's mobile
device is an incredibly precious
resource so i want to call this out as
an explicit goal
even though it's hard to directly
measure
the best way to optimize battery life is
well to only do work when you need to
this may seem pretty obvious but all the
things that we've talked about in this
lesson are applicable to this
in fact network usage computation and
rendering are all heavy indicators of
battery usage but the other apis we'll
talk about later can also affect this
for example using the gps changes
battery usage as does the camera
one final comment there are several
tools out there that will analyze your
page for you and make some suggestions
about how to improve your performance
my personal favorite of course is
pagespeed insights which is a google
tool that you can point at any website
and it will give you feedback on your
performance with that and the tools
you've acquired in this lesson you're on
your way to designing performant web
apps in the problem set we're going to
be going over testing the conference app
with pagespeed